it was meant to be the culmination of a
century of Nicaraguan dreams the
country's very own great canal linking
the Pacific and Atlantic oceans when do
built by Chinese billionaire handed a
generous concession by the government in
2013 everyone was talking about it we
found not as stones been laid at this
point there was a big ceremony to
inaugurate the building of the canal but
as you can see six years later there's
nothing here but a dusty road
why has the canal failed to materialize
the short story the billionaire lost
most of his billions before work could
get started
but the ripples are still being felt
particularly in the form of a law passed
especially for the project that says any
properties needed can be expropriated
that law is still on the books there's
still the risk that thousands of
campesinos could have their land
expropriated and occupied by private
interests that's why the citizens demand
that the law be struck down it's a
permanent worry for cust Elinor and her
family when the canal was first planned
workers showed up to measure out their
house when they protested things turn
nasty they almost broke our heads the
National Guard had us lined down on the
motorway and if we lifted our heads they
stomped on them they swore at us hit us
with sticks they broke my brother's ribs
it was just a full state of widest state
repression in the country
when police ransacked and then occupied
her office Monica Lopez fled to Costa
Rica
Castellanos family still fears they'll
be targeted again well this government
is in power we are not safe everyone
that they grab them put in jail is at
risk and the government still budgeting
for the Canal Authority it set up
despite the lack of progress we went
from office to office looking for the
man who heads it Manuel Coronel but
couldn't find him our interview request
to the government also went unanswered
to all intents and purposes it seems
this is now a ghost project but while it
exists at least on paper it's still
hanging over those who never wanted it
in the first place John Holman al
Jazeera Nicolai one